we gotta talk Grey's Anatomy I'm so
excited for the new season we have some
new doctors showing up how do they shake
things up well you know it's the season
of love and what do you do is bring a
lot more possibility into the hospital a
lot more potential coupling and
complications so it's it's gonna be a
lot of fun yeah I have to ask you in the
trailer we see Meredith in bed with
DeLuca what is that about
what are you thinking surviving it's a
dream you think it's a dream I think
Scott Speedman is gonna show up oh you
know these are these are good ideas I
think that you know I think you guys are
just gonna have to wait and see and and
I would love to see a pole I want to see
somebody do a poll of what people are
hoping for you know Jackson and Maggie
where does that love then that
relationship go well you know they're
new so it's still just building right
now I mean we're a few episodes into
shooting and they're they're getting to
know each other they're finding their
what what the quality of their
relationship is obviously with April
leaving Jackson grieve over the loss of
April there is definitely there are
definitely still traces of of April in
his life obviously there so Harriet
there there's still the the season picks
up just a very day after Jo and Alex's
wedding so so you know it's all still
very present are we gonna see Maggie
play stepmom a little bit a bit possibly
very possibly she's very good at it I
mean you've seen her with Maggie's cat
okay with Meredith's kid right
and of course Kim Raver is gonna be back
in full swing and she's pregnant
what does that mean for Owen well
there's a love triangle there that is
just a mess waiting to happen and Maggie
finds herself smack in the middle of it
because she went to treating teddy
so um yeah so it's a big it's a it's a
it's a it's a bit of a love triangle
it's a bit of that same old good old
Grey's Anatomy romance huh I can't wait
to watch it
I'm so excited have so much fun tonight
[Music]